a show of hands of how many people in
this room would consider cooking their
love language oh yeah what did you say
meaning if your partner would cook for
you you that's when you feel look what
if it's delicious
because if someone cook for you and you
have to eat some disgusting [ __ ] and you
pretend that it's so delicious that's
not but isn't isn't everyone a little
bit cuz everyone's moms made something
for them right and it's a little bit
you're like Oh mommy loves me would you
mind real I hate my mom but if she made
me food I'm like oh thanks mom you're
breaking down psycho is that considered
is that can I think so I think it's the
gesture I I appreciate something and
it's a primal need that's yeah I need to
eat to sustain myself and you're doing
that for me and I don't need a lift a
finger all right it's like a girlfriend
jacks you off like that's my love
language that is that's a really good
lovely okay like let me rephrase it a
little bit like if your partner cooks
for you would that turn you on like
horny yeah yeah I don't know if I would
just get up one er about eating like a
hamburger that my girlfriend made me
little girl microwave chicken pot pie
and as always eating it on the counter I
got a [ __ ] that's really sick dude
and also the white trash is sugar so are
you saying like the food comes and after
you eat it you're like I need a [ __ ] you
pack no warning off of them [ __ ]
fried that [ __ ] fish on them compared
to the other Ling love languages right
first is like gamma saw that sign
attacks of service to you or like oh
you're so handsome
like that words of affirmation yeah it's
when they're [ __ ] you're making no no
I think massage is there a little bit
sexier yeah but that's not acts of
service
yeah yeah because then you work on
hearing it too massages earlier so
getting Sasha no I don't like getting
soft you know I like to Sasha but I
don't like to get some really weird
weird no that's not perfect that is
weird partner I always want that like I
think about it just massaging the butt
for an hour so he's like [ __ ] I would
pay another man to massage you what wait
- I'll meet you after that's not what I
thought I figure a naked man on top of
you massaging y-yeah no naked man
massaging her okay I think if you told
that story about you how you had a
massage from a guy he got turned by oh
yeah I did get turned on oh and the one
where he's where he's talking about how
the Saudi guys wanted to come cook for
him naked maybe was that story oh my god
dude what what is going on man there's a
lot there's a lot of guys in the DM z--
man a lot of them are just rules yeah II
know I don't want to play a fire though
well you tell these stories I mean if
someone was interesting you these
stories they're gonna be like maybe I
have a chance no chances please stop
right this study which pulled 2,000
Americans found that 71% said that
cooking is their love language that's
pretty up there yeah there's a lot and
then also 86% of Americans found cooking
to be a total turn-on and 81% of those
like horny or just makes you happy a
turn-on like it's just it's attractive
oh it's not sexual but like just torn
yeah I think so I mean you could be
attracted to someone sexually and not
necessarily sick like it makes me happy
yeah yeah dude I saw this one video this
girl it was going around viral she was
like yeah
during quarantine I made a meal for my I
like to cook so I made a meal for my
husband every day right and it's just a
compilation of her busting out like
she's just following a hand with the
play like this and and he's just [ __ ]
playing video games every single day and
she just busts out and it's like
different plates every day there's like
spaghetti [ __ ] beef from Brock that's
like oh my [ __ ] god dude he needs to
stop being so perfect
tell me about it I'm like letting him
play video games
Wow dude I know right I'm just like what
the [ __ ]
what was he playing I don't know what he
was planning on crossing yeah [ __ ] you
man
animal crossing bro fun maybe I'll get
to play it sometime soon Nikki's really
been playing at the most but I like to
watch her play it yeah and I know that
someday I'll get my turn I just kind of
like are you can you can pop up and play
both on the same at the same time on the
same switch yeah but Nikki doesn't like
me because I don't I can't keep up oh
you tried doing that and I just keep
disappearing off screen and teleporting
yeah I'm always like ah look really it's
pretty nuts yeah so she like so much
better when I don't play second switch
just so they can play with each other
now oh dude I get why cuz I'm like oh
man that keeps so fun I can't wait to
play sometime it's my turn now except
it's never my turn them but yeah just
buy a new switch for yourself I'm not
sure that's the only way they're selling
out the song everywhere everyone was a
realist rising it's a craze yeah do you
have this crate you're in the Nama craze
I'm not playing at my girlfriend's
playing it completely but I've been
seeing like back-alley deals of people
selling switches if I'm running out to
like get dinner or something and I'll
just see people meeting in the parking
lot with like their animal crossing
switch which is a big deal right now
it's one that looks really cute
it has animal crossing people on it and
it has it like nice new colored
controllers and stuff and those are
impossible to find and I can go on a
rape for one the triple a normal switch
it's crazy yeah yeah yeah but yeah I've
been seeing like back-alley deals of
switches there's gonna be a black market
for gym equipment and Animal Crossing
people need to combine the two the mouse
trying you don't got one now you can be
played on a treadmill cuz switch is so
cool you put the little screen up there
and you get the little things but anyway
back to the survey here so then they're
saying 81% of those who are married or
in a relationship said that they are
still very impressed when their partner
cooks them a meal I think when it's like
like if there's for me if there's like a
hot chick
if she knows how to cook she immediately
just got hotter that's true I don't know
if it's because it's like the hot chick
that also knows how to shred on guitar
which is the additional skill but it's
like there's something about like
someone that's already attractive and
now they also know how to do this Wow
you're also a racecar driver yeah I feel
like if somebody is good at something
they're instantly margin but if they're
not attractive already and they have a
skill they're still not attractive to me
it's true cuz it's like when they're
good at something it's like they just
turn on their God mode Oh God at this
you know and then when they're in the
god lens you're like oh [ __ ] I'm with
the goddess or a god you know yeah dude
I mean when Bill Gates is on stage he's
he's like we would like to announce or
quarterly profits oh my god he's the
hottest girl I've ever seen the hottest
saw you with all those zeros next to his
[ __ ] bank account oh no wow that's
pretty godlike well would you guys
consider being a romantic home-cooked
meal romantic taliano microwave chicken
pot pie with a [ __ ] weight fairly
fresh yeah yeah cuz the the top ten that
they have here I'll just leave number
one is at 40% it's taken potatoes I was
gonna say steak but why is that romantic
though
I don't understand how do you guys heard
of steak in a [ __ ] day taking a
[ __ ] well cuz there's there's a thing
you never heard of that steak and
[ __ ] day oh I heard a steak a lobster
steak and a blow job day is like you
know how Valentine's Day is basically
for the chicks yeah the idea is taking a
little debate I don't know when the [ __ ]
it is cuz it really took the man yeah
yeah I would be the man so it's like hey
make me a give me a [ __ ] tonight I'm
being really cool but don't girls like
steak to not the bacons girls like pasta
I come to pastas romantic right just
like I like steak [ __ ] take this
after all you won for tonight sumit they
speak and uh what was it what's the term
sticking Oh Jojo likes making a [ __ ]
number two here it is pasta and garlic
bread up 34% yeah I like steak with
pasta you like making me that oh yeah
and then let's just combine it all over
one and two right there done
pasta does go really well with steak I
don't know why it's just a great combo
and ralick bread if you don't have a
girlfriend it's taking a blow job that
you can make yourself a steak and then
suck your own dick dude I saw a video
where a guy sucked his own dick
yeah you showed us all that picture
allows the picture did you watch all my
picture enough to you watch all of it no
okay you laugh more than entire video
about the [ __ ] picture when we were
trying to cover a new story less I'm
sorry
I know Waldo is this other one okay so
you know how you don't really know
what's in the porno until you click it
what yeah no the thumbnail you think
it's gonna be so I got baited and
switched right so it was a it was a
threesome you know so I was like ooh you
know two girls one guy nice right so you
click the video and then the guys like
beating off in the room right and then
the girls like spying on him and he
starts sucking his own dick first off I
just signed up for this now I'm just
like what the [ __ ] dude are you were you
upset because you were jealous that you
how do you reach well he had a big-ass
dick so it's probably easier to [ __ ]
reach but on the bed like this and he
did one of these you know flexible oh I
can't take away from his mobility
are you sure that wasn't in the title no
it wasn't no what's the thumbnail big
selling point right that's the first
thing that happens no it was like it was
like him because I can't like doing a
girl and another girl but like it's like
you don't think that that's gonna happen
right so he's sucking his own dick and
then the girls come up and they're like
you don't need to do it yourself and if
they start getting it on right by like
it was a director it was so like okay I
was like what how far just happened was
that and uh in the tags and
I don't know no selfie except the taxi
for you on video after I saw that I
search engine optimization right I don't
know I mean when you hi just couldn't
even focus on the actual sex because
after that I skipped it and they're like
doing it doing regular threesome [ __ ]
right but I was like why don't you
continue the video later I would be so
scared of what happens next watch myself
I feel you bro I feel you let me just
you know you've got to do the 10 to the
10 second route forward thing right I
was like alright so I went forward and
I'm trying to figure out wait did I just
see what I just saw I don't want to go
flat every line but that's probably what
[ __ ] happened
but now I can't even finish because it's
just I just watch the guy suck his own
dick me a video that when the first
minute a guy sucking his own dick
I'm out of there right you're you you
skipped to the end where he's getting
double fisted by two chickens and that's
another story for another time I swear
to God about how these things happen
dude you know just like that time there
was a I find it was lesbians and then
she goes down and kisses her stomach and
it's a hard dick and she starts sucking
it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]